hey everybody welcome back to planet
coaster and join me as I try to embark
on a new journey to build another roller
coaster after I've already been running
too many projects at the same time but
this one I actually started for a pretty
interesting reason it's very similar to
grapefruits and it's actually during the
time that I was working on the
grapefruit that I felt like also trying
to make a realistic wooden coaster then
I figured this would be a very
interesting project to try and take a
shot at so melissa's basically in this
series I'll be trying to make a GCI
wooden coaster and for those of you who
do not know what I'm talking about
or do not know how the hell I'm gonna
try to achieve that I'll try to explain
more of that throughout this video but
basically in essence I'm trying to build
a wooden coaster in a realistic is
possible way in a way that I've never
actually seen before in planet coaster
so for those of you weren't familiar
with GC I and what it is exactly
GC I or what the name actually stands
for which is great coasters
International is a company that
manufactures wooden roller coasters the
truth is a little bit more complicated
but you can generally see it as GCI is a
company where wooden coasters come from
or released some wooden coasters and as
a result many of their coasters are just
referred to as GCI coasters few good
examples I think or gold striker at
where is that thing again
California is something California's
Great America I think it is I I hope I'm
not upsetting anybody I should have done
my research a little bit better but yeah
that yeah that's the point and also for
those Europeans out there Vodun at
Europa Park for example or Troy at
Overland or if you're from China then
wood coaster which is the lamest name
ever for a coaster but probably one of
the best layouts ever and ironically
possibly one of the best wooden coasters
on the planet so they've actually gotten
quite a few wooden coasters with a very
good reputation out there but the thing
that I think is is very special about
the company
is that you can really tell that they
have a different way of creating their
coasters and definitely toward the
uninitiated which was me for the longest
time you can't really see much of a
difference between wooden coasters from
one manufacturer and wooden coasters
from another manufacturer they're all
out of wood they all look more or less
the same the track looks very similar
the catwalks look very similar but the
thing that makes great coasters
international coasters really stand out
is their track work the way that layout
is made the sort of transitions it has
the way that it writes most of all there
are very unique coasters and they're
extremely hard to make that they I
always thought that their coasters were
very similar to another manufacturer
called gravity group who's made coaster
like the voyage or ravine plyo to
particularly there is a world of
difference between these two
manufacturers and other manufacturers of
wooden coasters out there as well and
where gravity group wooden coasters are
quite easy actually to make and design
since their layouts are very
straightforward in track shaping and you
basically just have to make sure that
they're pretty smooth for great coasters
international coasters it's so much more
difficult than that's and they have a
very signature style of designing their
coasters and to be honest I have never
ever seen a realistic GCI in planet
coaster routes of course possible that
people have been doing this but so far
I've never actually seen one that really
made me feel like it was a GCI coaster
and the same almost goes for no limits
even I know there are many people who
have tried it and I know that there are
actually a lot of creations out there
who do a really good job at trying to
emulate the the GCI style but it's
always really difficult to get to it
exactly and as a disclaimer I should
also say at the start of this video that
I don't think I'm gonna be successful at
it much at all in this video either it's
just so damn difficult to get that sort
of track shaping precisely the way that
GCI does it but at least I wanted to
give it my best shot
in planet coaster to try and see how far
we can actually push this coaster
creator and
see how realistic we can actually make
certain types of coasters so I think
it's about due time that actually talked
about why GCI coasters are so unique so
there are quite a few things to factor
it in but one of them and this is
something that you might you might start
noticing if you watch a lot of POVs of
GCI coasters especially ones like Troy
or El Toro
that's blown Park in Germany they have
super snappy transitions there are
always these little moments when going
from one curve to another or even in the
middle of a curve where the track just
sort of moves in such a way that there
is a little pop of airtime on it so
there will be some curves that maybe go
horizontal and then after just a little
bit they just suddenly dip vertical
before returning to be a regular curve
again and in the middle of that curve
because of that sort of little dip where
you suddenly start going down you come
out of your seat for like a fraction of
a second and then you go again on the
curve and it's it's all of those moments
that sort of bring you out of your seat
that make sure that you you don't really
sit in there just comfortably well
they're always comfortable but you never
really stay in place on them there was
always these little moments where you
fly out a little bit and there's even
some moments where you're sort of thrown
in to the side for a little bit there
are always these little moments that
almost feel like they shouldn't be there
like it's a roller coaster tycoon
designed roller coaster where you know
in roller coaster kun there's this
moment where you have a curve that's
completely flat but you want to sort of
extend it into a curve that goes down
you always have that one track section
that has to go from flats to going down
gently while keeping the bank and after
that returning on the curve those are
the types of things that you actually
find on GCI coasters and yet they're
pretty smooth and quite comfortable but
it's just these little moments that are
one of the defining things about GCI
coasters there's a lot more complicated
things going on in the background that
honestly I don't really understand
because I'm not an engineer in any way
and I haven't really studied for any of
this nor do I have any
experience in fe D or anything like that
it's much more complicated than what I'm
saying but I think this is probably one
of the easiest ways to illustrate it to
somebody who's never heard about it
before and and this is the sort of
wooden coaster look and feel that I want
to try to get as close to as possible
with planet coaster with this coaster
now there are a few other things there
are quite a few other things that I had
to keep in mind while building this
coaster one of them is that I wanted to
make the entire thing out of four meter
sections since even though GCI coasters
will throw you around and have all of
these strange transitions that don't
look like they're smooth they are
actually quite smooth and they're quite
a comfortable experience especially with
those beautiful millennium flyer trains
which are these new trains that recently
came out with one of the latest updates
of planet coaster and I was super happy
to finally see these trains in the game
and also there's another reason that I
wanted to go for four meter sections as
well the reason being that it gives you
a lot of control over the banking versus
the way that the track is actually going
so one thing about GC is is that their
layouts is designed separately from
their banking now this I have to thank
Kyle Sloane for a lots of all right I've
already named him on my grapefruits
video since he was the one who
originally taught me about the four
meter method and he actually knows a lot
about GCI coasters as well he currently
works for skyline attractions which has
some relationship creating GCI coasters
I don't know the exact extent to warn it
but basically a lot of the former GC I I
please left the company and started
skyline attractions and now the two
companies are working together to create
TCI wooden coasters that much I can
probably say without going into slightly
of a territory where I probably start
saying things that are completely
incorrect so basically he knows a lot
about this stuff and I had a
conversation with him very long time ago
in which he helped me so you sort of get
a bit
an understanding of T psychosis I'm
pretty sure that I'm still very much a
new compared to anybody who actually
knows a lot about it but I was actually
a lot of very useful information spread
in there so one of them was the fact
that banking is done separately from the
layout so the layout is drawn and then
the banking is added later on and so
what really helps in planet coaster is
that you can at least have these two
things separately trying to get these
trying to get these transitions that go
from banking in one direction into the
other rights and also what's quite nice
is that we have separates control over
the curves left or rights and the
vertical position of the track which
just helps to get the transitions a
little bit better as well and it
actually helps in trying to create what
a DCI feels like because of a few
limitations I wouldn't really call them
limitations but because of the way that
they're actually designed now from what
I've heard from him and I haven't really
got this from any official source this
is just anecdotal evidence at this point
so if I'm saying anything wrong please
do correct me but from what I've heard
basically the way that these coaches are
designed is they're made out of all
these 2d plants so there's a top plan
being made there's a side view being
made and then last but not least the
banking is applied to that so you can
tell that the the way that all of the
movements of the track are actually made
separately so not only is the banking
made separately afterwards after
designing the layout itself but also the
heights is designed separately from the
this sort of 2d top view of the coaster
and all of this is done with just basic
shapes like circles parabolas and
straight lines and also sign transitions
which with my not limited knowledge
I can only say it's probably going to be
the the transitions between different
curves where even though the curves on
the GC I look very circle ish the
transitions between taking a curve to
the left or taking its curves to the
right will be a bit of a parabola where
it evens out
in the middle of it at least that's what
I'm pretty sure is going on there so the
design is actually quite simple in that
way but it's really smooth and it's
typically GCI instead of just designing
the whole layout in one go in a sort of
3d space and being computer calculated
that way
so that's really as far as I can talk
about that I'm probably quite a lot
better at just nerdgasm in over these
things to be honest I only have 2 GC ice
under my belts I've gone Georgian the
dragon at the efteling and Troy at
toverland and Troy is super amazing I
really love that coaster but that's not
really that much but you can definitely
tell the way that it's going on is very
different from other wooden roller
coasters and those transitions are so
damn good there are quite a few moments
on Troy for instance where you do have
that moment where in the middle of a
curve you you sort of strain out for a
bit and your direction vertically
changes so either you go up in the curve
and suddenly it starts straightening out
and then a curve sort of continues or
you do the opposite thing when you're in
a straight curve and then there's this
little pop more you just go down for a
little bit and you come out of your seat
for a bit and then you're you return
into the curve and those are really just
the moments that are really cool that
these rights or the way that when you're
going up a hill and it's sort of curves
on top of that hill wow it's banking and
getting into the curve the track already
flattens out a bit and then during the
curve you're sort of on a straight
circular curve so the transition from
going from a straight piece of track
into a banked curve that very transition
isn't just something where your your
body rotates a little bit to start
banking but it's one way you sort of fly
out of your seat and then you're sort of
thrown into the curve it's it's so hard
to describe it but they're they're so
awesome I do know though that they're
pretty controversial coasters there are
some people that are absolute GCI fans
in the coast community and some people
who don't really love them as much but
from the little bit of the tastes that I
have so far
I'm definitely quite a fan the one GCI
that i've never actually been on though
is wood coaster in China in Knights
Valley and this is one I think I'm I
drop it in the beginning a little bit
it's a really a mental coaster in terms
of layouts it's built on the hillsides
and that's what inspired me mostly to
built this coaster on the hillside as
well and it does a couple of other GCI
quirks as well CCI coasters very often
fly through their stations and that's
something that I wasn't able to get into
this coaster but it's still something
that you'll see many GC is doing at the
moment in the middle of the in the
middle of the ride where it sort of just
flattens out for a bit and it flies
through the station building and then
just flies out again and it's really
quite awesome since when you're standing
inside the station waiting for the ride
the car actually just passes by the
station and if you're lucky the whole
thing rattles and there's this big roar
of wood it's super loud but it's really
awesome and it's it's not just a great
way to get you pumped with the ride
itself but it's also a great sense of
speed while you're on the ride itself
and for Troy for instance I definitely
know that after you pass the station for
a little bit
you're being thrown down very quickly
again and there's these couple of little
moments where you basically just fly
everywhere in super rapid transitions
and it's one of my favorite parts of the
ride also another very typical GCI thing
is to have a curved drop there is a very
typical GCI curve drop which I can't
really get the exact shaping of in
planet coaster but doing the drop is the
one thing that I probably redid the most
out of everything on this coaster since
they have a very very typical drop that
it's a drop where you start going down
quite steeply but with a very gentle
curve like the top of the lift Hill is
kind of gentle curve and then as you go
down the drop you also start getting
into a curve you start banking and you
start flattening out the track and by
the timing at the bottom you're fully
into this circle of a curve and
sometimes the sources this bit of a
moment where you start going up again
which also put on this coaster see yeah
it's very typical of TCI coasters to
have a curve job there are some
exceptions George in the dragon in the
ætheling
being a dueling coaster has a straight
drop
nevertheless still really awesome or
wood coaster at night Valley is one that
has a sort of pre drop section that's a
bit interesting but that's really just
because it follows the hillside but for
many of the standard GTI coasters that I
just built on flatland and standalone
wooden coaster they have this sort of a
curve drop they also have a very gentle
lift so it's not very steep lift old
somewhere around 25 degrees I think at
least that's why I went for with this
coaster I don't know the exact amount of
degrees it's not really something that I
was able to Google exactly but it's a
really gentle incline for the lift Hills
is that something that I put in here as
well
another interesting facts about these
coasters apparently is that they never
go underneath a curve so there are but
there are actually very many moments on
GCI wooden coasters compared to other
coasters where the track goes underneath
another part of the track but never will
a GCI coaster go underneath a curve
since that's just supporting issues
apparently since curves are a lot more
difficult to support especially GCI
wooden coaster curves you can quite
easily tell GCI apart just by the way
that their their curves are supported
there are these slanted diagonal beams
coming out from the directions which is
which is very hard to describe I should
just put a picture up in here so yeah
you've got those very interesting
supports going on as well and basically
they don't really want to have to deal
with putting a piece of track underneath
that so usually TCI coasters go
underneath their own track on a straight
piece of track something which I
couldn't exactly follow on this coaster
even though you could probably tell by
now I've redone the layouts quite a few
times there are still some moments where
it sort of just slips underneath part of
a curve but I hope it's not too bad at
least there is no point where it really
sort of goes underneath the middle of a
curve and very clearly in a place where
you would want to have those supports a
sight note though I don't think I'll
quite be supporting this thing with GCI
supports it would be a hell of a law of
work since you basically have to start
from scratch
at all of the very typical supports to
it and basically do it beam by beam and
that's not something that I really have
to time for it to be honest I was
already quite mad
to put many hours into making these
layouts between the things that I didn't
record and between the redoing so every
part of this layout removing all parts
accidentally not saving this thing which
happened at some point and trying to
redo the first drop every damn time I
think I spent somewhere around like 8 9
10 hours or something like this on this
coaster it's not exactly something that
I'm very proud of but I enjoyed the
entire thing I don't know what's wrong
with me it was quite a lot fun to do it
so um at this point you're looking at
one of the lasts versions of this
coaster there was a reason that I
removed this version though it was a bit
too close to the park map and you could
tell that I was sort of ruining the
ending there just to be just to be clear
of the park map and that's something
which I later on figures and that's kind
of a shame it might just be better to
move the coaster redo the terraforming
and give my give myself enough space to
actually finish up this layouts in a
decent manner so that's something that I
ended up doing eventually but apart from
that from the first drop into the last
section of the track everything is
basically going to remain more or less
the same so I'll be doing or redoing the
last part of the track over here but the
rest is just going to remain the same
way that it was so I think it's probably
a good time to go through the layouts
it's kind of weird because I've never
actually done an episode where building
the coaster is the only thing that I've
been doing in the entire episode because
nothing no layout so far has taken as
much time so if we go through the layout
itself we start off with that first drop
that slick GCI curve beautiful drop that
I sort of butchered in-game but it was
my best try in the end and I was more
happy with this rendition than all the
other ones that I tried so yeah we're
starting out with that handing it to a
small hill in the middle of the curve
it's quite a long winding curve into
another transition
sort of like an airtime Hill transition
catch a bit of airtime as you fly over
into the other direction and take a
curve into the other direction then it
sort of starts going up the second
largest Hill of the coaster evens out as
it gets into the banking of the curve
and turns around and there's a bit of
little airtime moments and bits and bobs
where it does some shaky transitions and
at some points there's a point just
before you pass underneath the lift Hill
where it sort of touches the ground and
never leaves the ground again and at
that point it's basically just the
terrain conforming coaster one of the
reasons that I did that is because
there's still too much friction on the
coasters in bleonard coaster and that
mostly goes for the wooden coaster so
this wooden coaster unfortunately does
have quite a bit more friction than it
would have in real life so I saw doing a
terrain coaster out of this as pretty
much my only way to make this actually
realistic in terms of speed and have the
coaster keep its speed until the very
end of the ride because that's one thing
I should definitely notice about GC is
as well they just keep going like from
from the beginning until the very end of
the ride it just feels like you never
slow down they definitely do slow down
of course there's physics but the slower
you gets the quicker the curves become
the quicker that transitions become the
lower comes to the ground and you never
really lose that sensation of speed
until you hit the very final brake run
and that's something that I really love
about this coasters as well I should
Kalia say though that I made a bit of a
mistake a few minutes ago that was
actually not my final rendition of the
layouts I actually ended up messing with
the layout quite a few more times over
here so I took way too much time trying
to perfect this layout is basically what
I'm getting to
I also put admittedly a little bit to
add too much airtime on some of these
hills you definitely come out a little
bit more than you usually would on a GCI
coaster but that's not something that
I'm gonna complain about I'm perfectly
fine with that I think it's an
improvement if anything so I'm just
gonna keep that around hopefully it
won't be too
much of an issue there's a threat on the
no-limits exchange by Kyle in which
explains how to make CCI coasters and
mentions that you should keep the
negative G's to about minus 0.1 to 0.25
to than that it's fine so I'm gonna say
that it's fine that it runs a little bit
faster than that's hopefully it should
be okay then I'm hitting a few well more
negative G's on some of these hills than
just that although I am trying to really
keep it even among the entire layouts so
the first couple of hills pour about as
much is the final hills and the terrain
also helps to keep the sensation of
speed going throughout the layouts
that's why it's so close to the ground
at the end of the ride but yeah I
haven't really talked about the final
section yet final section is a little
bit different from the first section
since there aren't really quite as large
dips valleys and hills and it's more
about the curves the twisting very close
to the ground and the transitions
between those curves so you could
definitely tell that the speed is a
little bit less but the transitions are
a little bit quicker and there are more
of them so it should hopefully still
have the same sort of sensation of speed
going as the beginning of the ride and
also some shouldn't I've hit the table
right there
there are also some transitions that are
a little bit like the transitions of the
beginning of the ride so before this
final curve right here there's that bit
of a hill where it hopes from one curve
to another and where hops from one
direction into another direction has a
little bit of airtime on top downhill
and it's very similar to the first hill
of the coaster after the first drop also
I actually quite liked the infinity
symbol sort of layouts that we have
going with the curves some of those
moments were for example another
manufacturer like gravity group would
have just made the entire thing one
smooth curve but with a TCI coaster you
have that little bit where it
straightens out for a bit and
flattens out for a bit as well and you
have that tiny pop of airtime instead of
just the entire curve being one smooth
curve and it's just one of those typical
moments they at least tried to sprinkle
in there as much as possible to still
sell the idea of this being a GTI a
coaster even if the track shaping isn't
really realistically GCI now over here
at Lost's I'm actually done with the
layouts I forgot to save at this point
so I had to redo this point but it's
pretty much exactly the same as I'm
laying out here one last interesting
quirk the brake run is banked very
slightly because of the way that the
magnetic brake fins have to fit into the
magnetic brakes at the brake run so
because there's a bank that's Bank the
other direction and the final curve the
brake fin should fit in the brake slot a
little bit better
no one's highly sure about the
terminology there but it's something
that many GCI coasters do so it's one
little touch down I wanted to answer
this coasters well and with a little bit
of final smoothing this courses layouts
is done and with that said I would like
to end this video with a POV and a big
thank you for watching especially if
you've been able to cut your way through
all of this coaster ranting which has
been way more than I was hoping for and
way more than I've ever done probably
but if you're interested I could totally
recommend just going to YouTube and just
just search for GCI POV and watch all of
those things because they are so
beautiful and just look out for those
snappy transitions those weird little
moments in those courses those little
pops of airtime especially if you have a
mounted camera POV you can really notice
those moments and notice that even
despite all of that the coasters are
really smooth in any case that's been it
for this episode so thank you guys for
watching and I'll see you guys in the
next one